what's with the mask flu prevention my
body is finely tuned like a microchip
and the flu is like a grain of sand it
could literally shut down the entire
system my body's like
it's like a chip
no hey I'm Margarita karaoke Christmas
party that sounds like fun no that is
not a party there's only one party and
it's hosted by the party planning
committee and it starts at three o'clock
then why are there two flyers I
understand that this is confusing for
everyone let me explain there's a party
that starts at three right and then
there's a way more fun party that starts
at 2 45 right and if you're interested
in the way more fun party all the info
can be found here on our more brightly
colored flyer
I didn't see where it was
secrets stolen
from deep inside you know this song
already of course I do everyone knows a
song that's amazing the drum beats out
of time if you're lost you can look and
you will find me Time After Time if you
fall I will catch you I will be waiting
Time After Time Time After Time Time
After Time
good stuff it's never happened
ow
what happened
the bread on your desk I just picked it
up it's white hot
but Jim this garlic bread is cold what
no
it burned me
I'm in crisis at a time so you're saying
that I intimidated you no not exactly
Come on talk more about that tantric
Workshop I went to I was so into you
okay and you basically turned me into a
female version of yourself and then you
got bored dating me because you were
dating yourself
huh I mean I was jogging I hate jogging
jogging is the worst Chris I mean I know
it keeps you healthy but God at what
cost you stay here and have fun because
I'm gonna go out back and shoot hoops
with David Wallace okay oh
um don't mention that you and I are
dating because I think he might still
have feelings for me Wallace
what the hell have you dated like every
guy here
wow
okay you got me I so got you so none of
them
of course not
I mean you're kind of like my first
really
oh my God it's so easy it's not even fun
hey Jan not too good no offense but
maybe you think I'm going too fast
because you're going too slow then no
offense but I'm going slow because I
might lose my job okay no offense but
maybe that's a little bit of an excuse
for not acting on your feeling no
offense do not remember you having a
Nursing degree and feelings offense
that's rude I'm gonna go dance douche
her up dude
you came
yeah I had some encouragement
your sweaters on inside out
and backwards
it's been a tough morning
lots of regret and shame should be the
official slogan for snake juice
uh well uh this committee would like to
ask if you are the kind of candidate who
could forgive someone
after they behaved like a complete
jackass this candidate could
especially because this candidate also
behaved like a total jackass please
don't worry about it the committee
totally understands
also I can talk about my qualifications
for this position but first I am going
to go throw up in a wastebasket
would you mind if I joined you not at
all
yeah nothing you just concentrate on
turning around
hi I just just tap s then d
oh
any last words no what
wow
it's like go bad
well I'm I'm in a bit of a lull right
now but I'm so glad that you all have
people in your lives that you care about
so congrats
it's really hard to say congrats without
sounding sarcastic seriously I really
hope you guys are all very happy damn it
we are
hey
um
about the beach it's okay we all say
things without thinking oh no it's not
that I've actually been thinking that
for a long time and I'm glad I said it I
just I'm sorry if it made you feel weird
oh
okay
Pam is kind of a
and Perkins Chris hey I heard you were
back yeah I didn't do this because of
you well it looks great yeah you look
great am I right it's so good running
into you you know we should get together
soon I'd love to catch up me too ketchup
and mustard
ketchup and mustard
delightful I relish your whip
well I sausage your face
this is it for me promise me something
Jim
hey Karen
uh what are you doing here first of all
hi
what are you doing here you good
I'm just checking on the other branches
Michael wants me to do that from time to
time so do not tell Karen about the
industrial copier
copy that
I cried for weeks over that guy so yeah
seeing him climb out of a PT Cruiser in
a lady's Warehouse uniform
felt pretty good
hi Dave you're late and I can see your
nipples through your dress what no
really in nursing school we took a psych
course on how to treat phobias with a
method called exposure therapy
so like if you were afraid of snakes
they would immerse you in a tank of
snakes so I am going to immerse Leslie
in a tank of bad date you're 20 minutes
late I almost left okay well I was uh
dropping my niece off what's your
niece's name torpal what I don't know
that's not a name I don't have an ease
my niece's name is Stephanie stop lying
hey hi guys
oh my God
is that Jim's what's like a horse knot
okay wow oh man my head just exploded
thank God for everybody right okay
wow you're huge that's incredible
I God sorry sorry my head is I'm just
I'm trying to figure out the last time
that you and Jim had sex
and let's just get this over with shall
we